well guys bruce willis is
back at it with being bruce willis and i
gotta thank
everyone on twitter who has a verified
check mark
for what to put in my thumbnail today
you guys are all wonderfully original
bruce willis
went to a rite aid today he refused to
wear a mask
and then he got kicked out i guess you
could say
okay i guess you could say he thought
his life is also expendable
[Laughter]
maybe he has a sixth sense
for when germs are around oh oh or
perhaps he really does think he's
unbreakable oh
he has a death wish
remake reboot that's it for today's
video guys
we're done what films did you think
that's all we wanted to do is come in
here today leave your
buns down below fill up that comment
button
uh here he is in rite aid doing his best
all bruce willis movies impressions
seriously
goodness looks like he's wearing a
silicone mask of bruce willis
so he had a bandana around his neck his
neck apparently like some people were
uncomfortable
right had asked him to leave this story
is no surprise if you've heard any story
about pepperoni so like
none of this is a surprise it's bruce
willis it's so
unsurprising when you think about it
you're like yeah that's not a surprise
it sounds like something bruce i feel
like bruce willis is the kind of guy who
would actually believe in masks
and still not do it yeah because he just
doesn't give a [ __ ]
here's my thing about the mass situation
okay here's my thing about the mass
situation
tom cruise is a little more successful
so i'm going to listen
yeah bruce willis isn't on the phone
with everything there's the gold
standard
if a store or a place of business or any
place you go to that is indoors that
wants you to wear a mask
i think you should just cooperate and
wear a mask the other day
i went to see the optometrist next door
to it while i was waiting for
like a pair of contact lenses there was
a store next door that looked really
appealing and there was like
a couple people in there and when i went
to walk in the owner said oh can you
please wait outside first before
so these people can leave and my initial
thought was that's kind of freaking
annoying there's like two people in this
store what's the big deal and my
follow-up thought was
well it's her business so i'll cooperate
that doesn't make her comfortable you
know
it's just the way it ought to go masks
are not
the cure-all all right that doesn't mean
you have a hundred percent guarantee
you're gonna be safe they're like
a good vitamin they they help increase
your odds of preventing a disease
and why wouldn't you want that and if
you guys don't believe in vitamins
try this one out they're like a seat
belt for a car
does that mean if you get in a car
accident you're going to survive just
because you're wearing a seat belt
no but they're a good safety measure
okay
and plus you know you gotta look out for
the other people around you everyone's
trying their best
right we don't do that in america
everyone's trying their best
i say he should have just cooperated he
doesn't need to be
he doesn't need to act this way he could
wear the mask when he's in there and
take the mask off
once he walks outside of right early
second the torso you could take your
mask off go through the airlock bruce
i'm sorry you were not able to get
whatever cleaning fluid you needed for
your harmonica that day bruce willis you
know he's got music to make during the
pandemic he's going to drop an
album this year and it's going to be
great after he finishes beating the [ __ ]
out of a couple writing
i can just imagine being that writing
employee in that situation how
uncomfortable that would be
i'd be nervous i could say all the [ __ ]
i want with a camera pointer at me and
i'm making a youtube video
the second on that rite aid and bruce
willis is there now we're in a mess and
like i don't want to be able to tell
bruce willis
bruce willis i know that you're famous
for being a badass and having a temper
but could you please vacation
i don't know what the details are about
you know like
how he left i don't know if he threw up
a history through the window
he kicked out the doors bashed in all
the windows and left
one thing's for sure his face turned
red
and then uh uh oh and then he went the
whole
nine yards to not follow the rules of
cove
of the pan the the situation yeah
guys we really just wanted to come on
here to make some fun
puns and tell encourage you guys to
try on a mask once in a while if a store
wants you to yeah don't cop out ah
video won't stop oh my god john there's
so many come on in the new one you can
do it let's go to his imdb
here we go i mean one thing's for sure
he won't be
the last man standing twitter will
remain split
oh his decisions he's behaving like a
like a regular old
jackal yeah man you could throw him in
with 12 monkeys it's like he wants to
bring on the armageddon of his life you
know what i mean
he's a little out of his fifth element
if you ask me
and to think a perfect stranger had to
ask him to leave
he stormed out of there and walked 16
blocks in frustration
like an alpha dog you know what he was
muttering to himself when he left rite
aid right what was that they said go to
the store
have a good day pick up your pills are
you okay anyway guys
leave your thoughts down below on this
it's uh
yeah where where your mask or your mask
it's the least you can do
your masks take it off once you step
outside right you can even get a fun one
just a cooperation get one with bruce
willis on it
bruce cooper